I gotta start off with you know keeping
secrets okay so the the cliffhanger at
the end of last season with you know we
didn't know if you were coming back and
then fan reaction was bonkers all over
the Internet's we're like how could you
play with my emotions how difficult is
it to keep those things a secret in
today's day and age with the internet
it's nearly impossible I know it and
then if like we take a picture on set
and we posted a mindful of that too we
don't want to give it away we try to do
it for a while I was like let's not have
don't post a photo of me but then
eventually you know we're working out in
the streets of Chicago so I'm wearing a
white shirt yeah and it's not like an
angel sure I'm not dead but ya know it's
really hard so I mean any people want to
find out I can find out but you know so
you can you can use it or not you know
who in your life is like always hitting
you up for spoilers about the show like
they want to find out what's going on
before I mean I have aunts who ask me
all the time they're like so can you you
can be a secret I'm like if you tell
anybody it's obviously like one person I
trust yeah I usually just dangle the
carrot in front of you yeah you got a
much more fun to watch you guys squirt
right it's true people want to be teased
this isn't it yeah well I mean because
the funny thing is
I'll come into this like oh I mean like
I'm looking for some spoilers some some
story tips the second half of this
season and you all will do the exact
same thing yeah that's true I mean
you'll have to see yeah and it's I mean
it's great cuz we loved the suspense
that's what we want right but you guys
tell me something like now that you're
now that you're promoted to captain
uh-huh right how does it affect the
dynamic of the team he's well he's I
mean it seems a bit different so there's
I guess even more responsibility now
he's not on even keel with severide so
it raises the tensions and the drama
between us in some really good incidents
and there and there happened to be you
know you could do the call one way or
the other you know there's more than one
way to skin a cat
and then sometimes things go wrong and
then it really comes down on my
shoulders now we have less of a shared
responsibility and I'm more you know I'm
responsible so that's I mean it's it's
more pressure on the character but it's
I mean it's great because it creates new
tensions which you know I've come from
all existing tensions so I so it ties
together a lot of things quite nicely
and I like being the captain now yeah
like it and I was like oh it feels weird
but now I'm like yeah yeah so it's good
to watch Casey come to own it as well do
you mean be responsible and you know
power responsibility yeah how does that
affect your characters relationship now
I mean it doesn't it's sexual tension
you know I think that Casey and Dawson
now have are in a good swing of things
well she's the captain really yeah I
just let him think well there's a new
romance blossoming yeah everyone loves
to [ __ ] these ship names right so what
do you thing about the stellar ride are
you on your one board I do like Stella
ROG yeah I think there are goods yeah I
think they're a good match I mean I
don't know I actually don't know what's
gonna happen with that I don't know
they're gonna end up together or you
know they're gonna I hope they play it
out because it's nice I'd like to take
you see more like friends who can write
get each other benefits but will it
transform will it blossom why No
well you told you I mean Yura I told
your family so they know what happens we
don't know
[Laughter]
I only read my part one of my best
friend's is a firefighter and his
brothers a police officer and they're
always like ribbing each other it's
always friendly competition is that sort
of friendly competition between you guys
and the guys and PD oh absolutely yeah
of course and we have to have to bust
each other a little bit come on you know
even like different shows but the fact
that we have five minute cops and I do
hang out there friends is all it's all
in good fun but yeah that's uh yeah
that's the thing they actually do and I
like that so we kind of do it naturally
you know once you're in those roles is
sort of like it does itself you know